hello guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Katie
dubov Katie and I are gonna check out
the trailer I said it's like same [ __ ]
every [ __ ] video don't I will mix it
mix it up hey guys I'm Ryan Wright guest
and then we're gonna check out the vid
like well what's a different way of
saying check out we're gonna tune in
we're gonna yeah watch scope scope we're
gonna scope we're gonna scope out the
video for the Danish girl as the sound
is good part Clark no first time we met
she propositioned me she's feeling
special
I was sure who is so sure
so Tommy reading speech with me so maybe
like that you why I know everything
he'll aim is alright could you help in
something you will not tell anyone about
it
hello dreadful is he gonna call you Lily
I want to sketch you Lily
we should go out tonight give them
something gerund
Lily you're exquisite
doesn't like a woman yeah you're
different from most girls I said I need
to ask your permission before I kissed
you
he's hot man uh no he's pretty
good-looking that what happened last
night since there was a murder and I
wasn't me there was a moment where I was
just yelling but he does like we were
playing a game
he's lost his way needs a friend
let me out I think Lily's thought I'd
come in my dreams she's always there I
need my husband now you hold my husband
right the fact is I believe that I'm a
woman
and I believe her too oh so she has
never been attempted before
Wow the hell it could kill you
it's why only up this is nobody I had to
let it go
I love you because you're the only
person who made sense of me
made me possible he looks like Bryce
Dallas Howard who is hot yeah he looks
he looks hot please giving me crap about
my phone sorry you smell that
know what it smells like he's gonna get
another Oscar nomination it's good one I
thought that was really sweet god I mean
the search for like identity yeah
present it was heartbreaking when he was
breaking down at that table I was I
found myself like mass just a trailer
but I don't want to cry alright I had
shivers I was I got the nipple chills
again the NIP chips man Oh
powerful so this is the true story of
the first person who was like did it's a
true story I missed that yeah it's ever
inspired by the real events or somewhere
but it must have been the first
operation Wow for though what an
interesting story there are so many
movies now about like transgender or I
don't know the actual word for the
twenties changer set transsexual sexual
transsexual okay there's a lot of
stories of that now but this looks like
one that's really interesting yeah I
would love to see it seen like I would
love to see it for his performance alone
of a man who really feels like he's a
woman that that sounds heartbreaking to
actually because in that time so not
acceptable and supposedly if this is
true story this is surgeries never been
attempted before like for something like
this
what an interesting concept to explore
what people were responding to how
someone responds to this in a day and
age where it's it's already hard enough
today to it for someone to accept that
yeah I could only imagine what it must
have been like back then terrifying I
think terrifying terror is the word I
know this when I talk you really think I
do you actually think before you speak
something I don't do often just like
nothing it's good in bed yeah mmm I just
like the feel and say which gets me in a
lot of trouble where
Gagan nice really nice it's a good day
today I need to grow up well it's
beautiful I mean that the aesthetic is
gorgeous
the fact that they center this around
the manufacturing of clothing yeah I
think it's really interesting because
then it's like the texture and the lace
and all of a sudden this man feels
completely at home mm-hmm so it makes
sense to put it in that world I just I
think that's a beautiful approach and
what I would like really interesting
husband-and-wife story like I don't know
if they stay together in the end or
something but the fact that she gets to
a point where she's like supportive of
this that was that was kind of touching
actually that's very moving trailer it's
just a trailer but I'm like emerging
trend I kind of know the movie now yeah
you know this is one of the few
circumstances where I'm okay with the
fact that they gave us so much I still
want to watch it and Eddie Redmayne
looks [ __ ] gorgeous beautiful like
when he's a what like dressed like a
woman I was like I boner you know yeah
it just makes it makes us able to accept
with our eyes the transformation that's
happening I will never look at Steven
Hawkins the same river again hmm because
he played Steven Hawkings great theory
of everything no no I know yeah talented
I lick his [ __ ] if you had one maybe he
will be laughing maybe by the end of the
movie we'll see a shot of the clip
probably not that's come on man it's a
Danish girl you know how them Danish is
no I don't I don't know I mean one thing
that I I'm picking up on is that I feel
like this true story is a little
Hollywood it out you know what I mean
okay I don't get the sense of like this
is the most accurate depiction but I
feel like the points and messages can
still be felt despite whatever
inaccuracies there might be I don't know
the story it's just so it's just like
this looks a little familiar in certain
ways that I'm picking up on that but at
the end of the day I'm just going to
accept it for what it is and I'm sure
it's going to be a phenomenal
performance
you know like even though the movie
itself it's a great director I'm hoping
that with a great director you get a
great film but even if the films not
that great the performance is I'm sure
gonna be solid oh right right off the
bat when he says um he says like
something changed I think oh my god
everything changed everything like so
yeah it just draws you right in it's
like the theory of everything changed
for him 1 2 1 2 come yeah so weak mind
body anyway guys thanks for tuning into
the channel today if you're new to it
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out Katie to boss channel
which as of our talked earlier there
will be more videos coming soon right
yeah you could follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope she
has an Instagram now and uh would you
want shut up I want to shout out Dennis
- Dennis Q who's Dennis Q he is a
student at one of the school's very
teaching ok and he knows of this channel
he does he's actually a huge fan of
yours oh yes yeah Dennis what's up Q hey
listen look I'm not gonna tell you what
this sentence means exactly this
question but trust me when you're 18
it's gonna come in handy is this
inappropriate no no no it's under
propria it's not okay especially cuz I'm
not gonna explain what it means - okay
just say does it look like a cue to you
I don't know what that means good just
remember there's gonna be a time and
you're gonna say does this look like a
cutie ah I wish I could explain the joke
that I would get her in trouble at her
job